[Music]
sans were stunned when Abby Lee Miller
announced that Aliano is coming back to
Dance Moms although there are some
obvious reasons as to why Eliana is
rejoining the team there are some
low-key ones as well watch until the end
to find out the real reason producers
want Ileana and Yolanda back on the show
I want to team each and every member of
the team has to pull their weight season
eight of Dance Moms has been
unpredictable and fans just don't know
what to expect things started changing
when Abby Lee Miller made the decision
to send Brady Farrar packing this just
didn't make sense
after all Brady was the best dancer on
the team in the end Abby made it clear
that sending Brady home wasn't easy but
it had to be done the team was relying
on Brady's talents to win competitions
and they weren't upping their game Abby
wanted her dancers to be a team and it
was clear that Brady was carrying the
dancers and outshining them left right
and center with Brady gone the girls
wouldn't have someone to lean on and
they'd be forced to strive for greatness
all the while improving their technique
but unfortunately for the ALDC things
didn't go as planned in season eight
episode six
Abby realized that her students weren't
pulling their weight they made tons of
mistakes during their performance and
ended up scoring fourth place and if we
know one thing about Abby
it's that fourth place is simply
unacceptable she was obviously
distraught over the fact that the girls
didn't win so she came up with a plan to
rile them up Abby kept on telling the
girls that they needed to prove that
they could win without Brady you don't
have Brady
to camouflage and although they were
confident at first things just didn't
work out Abby grilled the girls over
their many mistakes she told them that
they had timing issues galore with Brady
out of the picture the ALDC suffered its
first loss as a team Abby explained that
Brady's departure clearly wasn't enough
to light the fire in the girls hearts so
she decided to bring a familiar face
back into the equation the Dance Moms
were totally stunned when Abby announced
that Ileana and her mother Yolanda were
returning to the ALDC but she justified
her decision by explaining that Eliana's
return would help the team spirit and
talent reach new heights according to
Abby Ileana is going to blend in with
the group while adding talents to the
equation
unlike Brady who stuck out amongst the
other dancers due to his talent and
gender Eliana will blend in flawlessly
Eliana knows a thing or two about
working with Abby Lee Miller she first
appeared on Dance Moms in season six as
part of the mini team and she joined the
elite team in season seven
Abby explains that Eliana would be a
good asset to the team because she can
be beaten and we all know that Abby is
fond of some healthy competition but the
news of Eliana's return hit the Dance
Moms like a ton of bricks
whereas stacy had her own reasons for
being unhappy with Yolanda's return she
makes you insane like she makes you
crazy
erin had some very selfish reasons for
not wanting Eliana on the team erin
voiced her concerns which revolved
around not wanting Eliana to outshine
her daughter Savannah in Abby's
point-of-view bring in Eliana back could
encourage her other dancers to work
harder than ever before whereas beating
Brady was pretty much impossible the
team could outshine Eliana as long as
they give it their all
although the moms aren't too happy about
the new comers I'm not happy lily is
choosing to take the high road
according to her Aliana can make or
break the team but no matter what
they're going to work together and
they're going to be friends maybe
Yolanda is my favorite person ever but I
still like Kelly on it so while we
totally understand why Abby is choosing
to bring Eliana and Yolanda back we
can't help but feel that there are a few
other reasons why the mother-daughter
duo have rejoined the Dance Moms cast
the most obvious reason for Eliana and
Yolanda's return has everything to do
with drama since Brady's departure the
Dance Moms have had little to fight
about every single day about Brady Brady
Brady Brady Brady it's out of control
are you happy all their daughters are
pretty much equal when it comes to their
craft so things are bound to get a
little boring and since the reality TV
show mainly focuses on the mama drama
bringing back the outspoken and
aggressive Yolanda will most likely
bring the show's views and ratings back
up another thing worth mentioning is the
rivalry between Stacey and Yolanda who
could forget the time that the Dance
Moms got into a physical altercation in
season seven episode 19 after Stacey
confronted Yolanda in the parking lot
Yolanda lunged at Stacey grabbing her by
the neck so we totally understand why
Stacey wouldn't want to Yolanda back on
the team but since season eight hasn't
had much drama as the previous seasons
producers were under the impression that
bringing Yolanda back could contribute
to the shock factor and boy were they
right why would you in season eight
episode 7 we saw the return of Ellie and
Yolanda and while some of the other
Dance Moms were trying to play nice
Stacie's claws came out relatively quick
you guys shouldn't even be here period
Yolanda grabbed her daughter and took
her to the bathroom for a little chat
claiming that Stacey was saying mean
things about her Yolanda's revelation
had Elian tears in no time so voila the
producers succeeded in adding some drama
to the show not only are the moms
teaming up on Yolanda but the girls are
seeing Ellie as a threat so while Abbey
was right in thinking that Eliana coming
back would raise the stakes this was far
from being the only reason why Ellie
rejoined the cast do you think Stacey is
overreacting is Yolanda really the
monster they paint her out to be tell us
in the comments give this video a big
thumbs up if you love Dance Moms and for
more videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows subscribe to the things
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]